thanks Amanda really appreciate being in
Seattle and enjoying this cool and wet
weather um I uh um want to discuss a
concept today and right off the bat when
I looked at the title and I saw the word
new in there I thought wow there is
nothing new I don't know if anybody
listens to Ted Talks they were talking a
few weeks ago on an episode about how
there's really nothing new in the world
and that we just sort of reinvent stuff
and so this is not new uh this is taken
whole cloth from uh the new zealanders
and from the the uh British aisles and
so with that if you're you know if you
have to have new you need to go
somewhere else but um it it is a good
concept of what we have some preliminary
data but it's a m mature technology and
it used successfully um in different
parts of the world where it does this
where it rains um frequently and it uh
uh during the winter feeding period so
I'm going to talk about three sets of uh
issues to just set the stage with what
the soil and water effects are from
feeding cattle um on pastures during the
dormant period uh that we have in in the
Mid-Atlantic uh part of the United
States
and then I'll talk about um wood chip uh
design and that's an a engineering
component and I I I failed to mention
that I have collaborators from uh
University of Vermont a biosystems
engineer Joshua Faulkner and a wood
scientist from Duck West Virginia
University who worked with uh wood chip
issues on these uh um feeding
areas and I'll I'll go into a little bit
biomass um preliminary data that that
we've come up with on on what's suitable
to
use so anyway within the midatlantic we
have uh uh about 1.1 million uh beef
brood cows and that's minuscule when you
look at you know the Plains and and or
or Texas you know it's like one County
in Texas could have um you know a third
of a third of this uh population so it's
it's not big but it's our main uh
activity um and our our herd sizes have
have increased you know we're we've
we've gone from in the last 30 40 years
from 15 to 20 head up to now 200 head
and so that puts pressure on our on our
pastoral systems and and we uh you know
initially we we fed square bales and we
had Barn kept animals and we we moved to
round bales and everything went outside
and there's some serious impacts with
that so what's a wintering site it's an
area where cattle are fed during the
dormant period um sites includes you
know stored feed um you you you have to
tram across to feed concentrates with a
tractor um sheltered area if if you need
it calf Hutches and a winterized uh uh
you know watering system to to uh um
complete the uh the system and this is
what we get you know I I I do this talk
to to Farmers all the time and you know
they just nod their head they see this
they're the they're the brown Donuts in
our pastures at the end of the winter um
and you know here's a beautiful spring
picture and you see a a pasture on the
other side that has not been used as a
uh dormant feeding uh winter area and
then one on on on this this Paddock and
uh the differences are
tremendous you know it's uh they all say
that they don't do tillage but they
really do this is this is a pretty
severe tillage in a saturated condition
um so what you know I go back and it's
like the thing is it recovers fast and
Farmers forget like that they you know
they get ground cover again and they're
like hey everything's okay and they go
on and then they're back in the same
situation so I like to to use this
classic study um that Owens at Al I met
these guys right before they retired
they're from uh kakon Ohio uh they had a
a wonderful ARS station there that was
uh closed down uh recently uh in The
Last 5 Years but they had monitored
watersheds across the place and and what
they did was they they uh did long-term
studies which we don't we can't afford
to do and which we don't do anymore but
they had a period of from 74 to 886
where they continuously used a pasture
they summer grazed and then they winter
fed on it and then they pulled the cows
out and they only grazed during the
summer for another period of years and
then the final period they only
harvested hay and the results um they
had 60% of their sediment loss occurring
during the dormant period um not
surprising but the greatest losses um
were during March to June um you know
and they had 40% of their loss during
April and that's when our hydrologic
cycle is really letting go we have a lot
of spring rains and and uh uh a lot of
uh tillage by the
cows so this is just a uh you know it
kind of gives you an idea of
precipitation precipitation was even
across all these years from 74 to 94
there's some there's some some uh um
fuzziness to it but look at the the
runoff events during this uh um 24 or 12
month use period of the pasture where
they where they uh had cows on it they
had compaction and they increased uh
runoff during that period and as soon as
they pulled the cows off and only had
them grazing those runoff events even
with the same sort of
rainfall uh activity dropped off you
know uh significantly and then during
the hay only again there was a a huge
reduction so we know that um you know
it's a just a nice um quantification of
the impacts of winter feeding on pasture
and then here's the the uh corresponding
sediment loss numbers and as soon as you
pull them off you know all your sediment
losses are during that winter feeding
period and are caused from from that on
in a pasture
system the kicker for me and this is
what I try to tell Farmers is that
you're you're killing your production
you you you know you've got um here's
here's June 1 and here's percent here's
here here's when you're getting back to
100% ground cover and and Through the
Years there were times when they were
well into the growing period and they
only had 60% ground um ground cover so
you know using your your your your money
crop as a winter feeding area does you
know it's a it's a huge conservation
effect to move those cows off of that
pasture
land in our neck of the woods and so
this is what what we stole from the the
uh new zealanders and and the Brits and
the Scots and the Irish um it's a it's
an engineered uh heavy use area they
call them out wintering p ads so if you
want to learn about how it's done and
what the the Deep research that's been
done go go look at the British work and
and and do a search on out wintering
pads so what you do is we have um really
good clay soils uh subsoils or B Horizon
we just create these these humps and we
put in drainage and we added uh uh 57
aggregate Stone a good size um gravel uh
at a at a foot deep and then we um added
our our wood chip base uh to
that and you know we do have local
materials uh and that's that's an
advantage we have a lot of uh uh Eastern
Hardwoods and a lot of scrap trees that
are not um uh valuable uh for the timber
industry so we can chip those up it's an
environmental benefit but there's some
cost and management to it and and uh
French over in England they just wanted
to compare cattle performance on inhouse
versus keeping these cows out on a wood
chip pad and and basically they found um
that the wood chip pad from feed intake
and and uh you know carcass weight uh
live weight we all similar or better
than than these other Management Systems
of keeping cow
in and so there was there's no sort of
physical detriment to having cows
outside in the
weather so here's a picture of of the
one that we put in it was a a very low
budget we had a Conservation District
that helped us uh establish this uh you
will notice that it's next to a uh nrcs
heavy um uh roofed winter feeding area
so we combined a out wintering loafing
pad with feeding area and they do
recommend not to feed on these out
wintering pads because you'll create too
much concentration of manure around the
feeding area so you feed somewhere else
so there's there's the drainage um uh uh
pits and there's the gravel there was a
drain pipe that went into those low
spots
um you can see our our deep soils with
uh
um and and this was the the out pipe and
so you do have to manage process water
and that scares our Farmers because for
them EPA looks at a pastoral system as
being benign and so they say oh well if
we pull cows onto a pad we're creating a
point source but I mean the the
economics have to come into play how
much damage are you doing to your
resource so we put in a standard septic
tank
and uh um within that septic tank we had
a a pretty nifty little uh device that
was on a pivot and what it did was it
allowed accumulation of effluent um into
the septic T tank the the flout would
come up to the to to a horizontal
position and then it would fill the pipe
and it would flop over and empty that
that tank all at once and that would
dose our vegetative Treatment Center um
and there's our there's our uh um
vegetative uh our dispersal pipe for our
vegetative Treatment Center we set up we
set up another one um at our animal at
our Dairy science uh uh Farm in
Morgantown and we just uh tapped it into
the Lagoon so those are your choices you
can either have a uh a treatment center
or put it in a tank where you can spread
it cows are very happy um they uh they
had about 50 head and they they uh kept
these cows um on this pad for about a 65
day period during the the highest peak
of our hydrologic
cycle so costs everybody wants to know
what what do these things cost and and a
wood chip pad and this is a dollars per
cow uh it's it's reasonably priced um in
England I I think that they probably cut
all their trees down so there's a little
higher cost um and roof winter this is
the standard roof winter uh feeding barn
and manure storage is considerably
higher um pouring a concrete pad or
gravel pad is uh gravel pad's about um
uh the same price or a little bit higher
uh stocking density uh is is uh you do
have to give the the cows about 110 ft
because you want them to be able to lay
down you want them to be have
comfortable and have have space um to to
uh not be crowded um and and so these
are these are comparables these are our
nrcs uh standards that we that we
compared this to because we don't have a
lot of uh um um
Alternatives so we we uh we had
a very preliminary uh uh sampling
protocol we we uh look we we did grab
samples at 12 storm events um you know
we'd run up you know hour and a half
whenever whenever it looked like we were
going to have a runoff event and go grab
a sample um or the county agent would
help us do that and we had a pressure
pressure transducer in the in the septic
tank so that we could count how many
many times that flout raised and so we
knew what what our um amount of of of
outflow was for the for the
system and we had reasonable numbers you
know we it again we compared this with
uh um an earn uh uh pad or a concrete
pad and we were comparable to a concrete
pad and we were much less than an earth
and um you know dry lot um for for
numbers and uh you know the the the
Brits have found that uh uh you know
their estimation is that 90 to 90% of
the nitrogen and phosphorus is is in the
manure that's sort of held in this uh in
this filter bed um that that uh uh the
cows uh loaf
on again and with uh um looking at uh um
runoff
coefficients uh again we were we were uh
um comparable with um concrete and we
were much better than than earn um and
you can see uh you know our non- winter
periods what happened was we had rain
events that stretched out to longer
times um uh between the rain events and
so the the wood chip pad acts as a
sponge and so the nice thing is that you
don't get an immediate runoff you get
some some capacity to hold a rainfall
event and then in the the warm weather
it'll actually evaporate back
out so this kind of shows that with uh
these are these are individual rain
events uh the bigger the the uh the
circle the the the the higher the amount
of of rain and and you can see that um
as as the duration of dry period as you
as you have periods of dry between your
events uh less runoff occurs so there's
that again that sponge effect to where
um you only after you get like repeated
rains day in day out then you'll that
the system starts to get leaky so it's
it's it's kind of a nice um system to to
moderate runoff um nutrients cycling
what do you do well um you you the
recommendations are to have um a layer
of chips that are the filter bed chips
in the lower area that are fist size
okay and those are difficult to find for
us because most American uh chippers uh
chip a very small chip and so we're
still struggling at finding that that
English style large chip for the base
but on the top you want a much more
comfortable finer chip for the animals
comfort and that gets pulled and spread
and and uh the English have found that
soiled wood chips um or
composted um you know if you if you
apply those you can get equal uh yields
at the same um you know application of
54 lbs of synthetic n so you can see
there's there's quite a tie up of of
nitrogen that would be slow release over
time which is kind of nice with a with a
woody
product and like I'll go back the uh the
the big chips there's no degradation so
you have to sort of sit and and pull
those off after the end of their life
which is about five to seven years and
then it's like what do we do with those
I'm I'm still I'm really curious what
the Brits do with their their big large
uh chips that you can't spread on the on
the uh pasture of
haand so this is just sort of a a
pictorial of uh um application rates and
and response over time to that top P top
portion that has to be managed routinely
on the on the pad so you know there are
disadvantages you have to have uh um um
you know repeat applications of a of a
thin layer um and and uh you do have to
deal with affluent management uh
prolonged freezing is an issue or is it
not an issue to me um if I've got frozen
ground I'll move my cows out onto frozen
ground where they can't destructively
tear it up um so to me it's like get
them off the pad and use it
strategically in the wet sloppy weather
um and sourcing wood chips I think that
that's uh a real issue and and I am down
to about a minute
um
so I'm not going to talk about uh wood
chip um Quality or uh but you can come
and talk to me about some of our
treatments there's our latest uh um pad
at the dairy farm and we are uh in the
process of asking for an enter and
practice standard uh for our state and
we just need to continue uh the work and
uh the forestry equipment piece is huge
getting the right chip for this
technology with
that I appreciate your
time one quick
question yes so if the sized wood shift
after 5 years is still fist sized what
determines that it's exceeded its
lifespan the the the permeability or the
functionality of the pad is no is so
clogged with manure at that point that
you have to pull it out and and you have
to have a flowthrough system it once it
clogs up it'll just start ponding so
every five years you have to refresh
that entire bedus the
pip that's right yeah